i now call the prime minister to make
you statement prime minister
thank you mr speaker and with your
permission i will make a statement on
the road map
that will guide us cautiously but
irreversibly
towards reclaiming our freedoms while
doing all we can to protect
our people against kobe today's measures
will apply in england but we're working
closely with the devolved
administrations who are setting out
similar plans the threat remains
substantial
with the numbers in hospital only now
beginning to fall below the peak of the
first wave
in april but we're able to take these
steps
because of the resolve of the british
public
and the extraordinary success of our nhs
in vaccinating more than 17.5 million
people
across the uk the data so far suggests
both vaccines are effective against the
dominant strains
of cobit public health england has found
that one dose of the fisa beyond tech
vaccine
reduces hospitalizations and deaths
by at least 75 percent and early data
suggests that the oxford astrozenica
vaccine provides a good level
of protection though since we only
started deploying this vaccine
last month at this stage the size of its
effect
is less certain but no vaccine
can ever be 100 effective not everyone
will take them up and like all viruses
kerbin 19 will mutate
so as the modeling released by sage
today
shows we cannot escape the fact
the lifting lockdown will result in
more cases more hospitalizations and
sadly
more deaths and this would happen
whenever lockdown is lifted whether now
or in six or nine months
because there will always be some
vulnerable people who are not
protected by the vaccines there is
therefore no credible route to a zero
covered britain or indeed
a zero covered world
and we cannot persist indefinitely with
restrictions that debilitate our economy
our physical and mental well-being
and the life chances of our children
and that is why it is so crucial that
this roadmap should be cautious
but also irreversible
we're setting out on what i hope and
believe is a one-way road
to freedom and this journey is made
possible
by the pace of the vaccination program
in england everyone in the top four
priority groups was successfully offered
a vaccine
by the middle of february we now aim to
offer a
first dose to all those in groups five
to nine
by the 15th of april and i'm setting
another stretching target
to offer a first dose to every adult
by the end of july as more of us are
inoculated
so the protection afforded by the
vaccines will gradually
replace the restrictions and today's
road map
sets out the principles of that
transition
the level of infection is broadly
similar
across england so we will ease
restrictions
in all areas at the same time the
sequence will be driven
by the evidence so outdoor activity will
be prioritized
as the best way to restore freedoms
while minimizing
the risk at every stage our decisions
will be led
by data not dates and subjected
to four tests first
that the vaccine deployment program
continues successfully
second that evidence shows vaccines are
sufficiently effective
in reducing hospitalizations and deaths
third that infection rates do not risk a
surge in hospitalizations
which would put unsustainable pressure
on the nhs
and fourth that our assessment of the
risks is not fundamentally changed
by new variants of covid that cause
concern
before taking each step we will review
the data
against these tests and because it takes
at least four weeks for the data
to reflect the impact of relaxations
in restrictions and we want to give the
country
a week's notice before each change
there will be at least five weeks
between
each step the chief medical officer
is clear that moving any faster
would mean acting before we know the
impact
of each step which would increase the
risk of us having to reverse course
and reimpose restrictions i won't take
that risk step one
will happen from the 8th of march by
which time those in the top four
priority groups
will be benefiting from the increased
protection they receive
from their first dose of the vaccine
mr speaker all the evidence shows that
classrooms
are the best places for our young people
to be
and that's why i've always said that
schools would be the last to close
and the first to reopen
and based on our assessment of the
current data against the four
tests i can tell the house that two
weeks
from today pupils and students in all
schools
and further education settings can
safely return
to face-to-face teaching supported by
twice-weekly testing
of secondary school and college pupils
families and child care bubbles will
also be encouraged to get tested
regularly
breakfast and after school clubs can
also reopen and other children's
activities including sport
can restart where necessary to help
parents
to work students on university courses
requiring practical teaching
specialist facilities or on-site
assessments
will also return but all
others will need to continue learning
online and
we will review the options for when they
can return
by the end of the easter holidays
from the 8th of march people will also
be able to meet one
person from outside their household for
outdoor recreation such as
a coffee on a bench or a picnic in a
park
in addition to exercise
but we're advising the clinically
extremely vulnerable to shield
at least until the end of march
every care home resident will be able to
nominate a named
visitor able to see them regularly
provided they are tested and wear
ppe and finally we will amend
regulations to enable
a broader range of coveted secure
campaign activities for local elections
on the sixth of may as part of step one
we will go further and make limited
changes on 29th of march
when schools go on easter holidays it
will become possible to meet in limited
numbers outdoors
where the risk is lower so the rule of
six will return outdoors including in
private gardens
and outdoor meetings of two households
will also be permitted
on the same basis so that families in
different circumstances
can meet outdoor sports facilities such
as tennis
and basketball courts and open-air
swimming pools
will be able to reopen and formally
organized outdoor sports will resume
subject to guidance from this point 29th
of march people will no longer
be legally required to stay at home
but many lock down restrictions will
remain
people should continue to work from home
where they can and minimize all travel
wherever possible step two
will begin at least five weeks after the
beginning of step one and no earlier
than the 12th of april with an
announcement
at least seven days in advance
if analysis of the latest data against
the four tests requires a delay
then this and subsequent steps will also
be delayed to maintain the five-week gap
in step two non-essential retail will
reopen
as will personal care including
hairdressers i'm glad to say
and nail salons indoor
leisure facilities such as gyms
will reopen as will holiday let's but
only for use by individuals
or household groups we will begin to
reopen our pubs
and restaurants outdoors and honourable
members will be relieved
there will be no curfew and the scotch
egg debate will be over because there
will be no requirement
for alcohol to be accompanied by a
substantial meal
zoos theme parks and drive-in cinemas
will reopen as will public libraries
and community centers step 3 will begin
no earlier than the 17th of may
provided the data satisfies the four
tests most restrictions on meetings
outdoors will be lifted subject to a
limit of 30
and this is the point when you will be
able to see your friends and family
indoors subject to the rule six or the
meeting of two households we will also
reopen pubs and restaurants indoors
along with cinemas and children's play
areas
hotels hostels and bnbs
theaters and concert halls will reopen
their doors
and the turnstiles of our sports stadia
will once again
rotate subject in all cases to capacity
limits
depending on the size of the venue and
we will pilot larger events using
enhanced
testing with the ambition of further
easing of restrictions
in the next step step 4
will begin no earlier than the 21st of
june
with appropriate mitigations we will aim
to remove
all legal limits on social contact
and on weddings and other life events we
will reopen
everything up to and including
nightclubs
and enable large events such as theater
performances
above the limits of step 3 potentially
using testing to reduce the risk of
infection
mr speaker our journey back towards
normality will be subject to resolving a
number
of key questions and to do this
we will conduct four reviews
one will assess how long we need to
maintain
social distancing and face masks
this will also inform guidance on
working from home
which should continue wherever possible
until this review
is complete and it will be critical in
determining how parliament can safely
return
in a way that i know honourable members
would wish
a second review will consider the
resumption
of international travel which is vital
for many businesses
which have been hardest hit including
retail hospitality tourism
and aviation a successor to the global
travel task force
will report by the 12th of april so that
people
can plan for the summer
the third review will consider the
potential role of covid status
certification inhaled in helping venues
to open safely but mindful of the many
concerns
surrounding exclusion discrimination and
privacy
and the fourth review will look at the
safe return of major events
mr speaker as we proceed through these
steps
we will benefit from the combined
protection of our vaccines
and the continued expansion of rapid
testing
we will extend the provision of free
test kits for workplaces
until the end of june and families small
businesses
and the self-employed can collect those
tests
from local testing sites
mr speaker in view of these cautious but
i hope irreversible changes people may
be concerned
about what these changes mean for the
various
support packages for livelihoods for
people and for
the economy so i want to reassure the
house
we will not pull the rug out for the
duration of the pandemic the government
will continue
to do whatever it takes to protect jobs
and livelihoods across the uk and my
right honourable friend the chancellor
will set out further details in the
budget next wednesday
finally mr speaker we must remain alert
to the constant mutations of the virus
next month we will publish an updated
plan for responding to local outbreaks
with a range of measures to address
variants of concern
including surge pcr testing and enhanced
contact
tracing we can't i'm afraid
rule out reimposing restrictions a local
or regional level
if evidence suggests they are necessary
to contain
or suppress a new variant which escapes
the vaccines mr speaker
i know there will be many people
who will be worried that we are being
too ambitious
and that it is arrogant to impose any
kind of plan
upon a virus and i agree
that we must always be humble in the
face of nature
and we must be cautious but i really
also
believe that the vaccination program
has dramatically changed the odds in our
favor
and it is on that basis that we can now
proceed and of course mr speaker there
will be others
who believe that we could go faster
on the basis of that vaccination program
and i understand their feelings
and i sympathize very much
with the exhaustion and the stress that
people are experiencing
and the businesses are experiencing
after so long
in lockdown but to them
and to them all i say that today there
really is
the end really is insight mr speaker
and a wretched year will give way to a
spring
and a summer that will be very different
and incomparably better
than the picture we see around us today
and in that spirit mr speaker i commend
this statement
to the house i know called the leader of
the opposition righteous star
thank you mr speaker can i thank the
prime minister for advanced site of his
statement
and for the telephone call between us
earlier today
mr speaker this is the third time the
prime minister's announced a plan to
come out of national lockdown
in the past we've emerged without
sufficient caution
without a clear plan and without
listening to the
science we can't afford to make those
mistakes again this
has to be the last lockdown now the
vaccine rollout of the prime minister
said
has been remarkable and i want to pay
tribute to
everybody involved it is the light at
the end of the tunnel
but if we're going to get there we have
to trade very carefully
so i'm glad the prime minister spoke
today of caution
of this being irreversible of assessing
the data
and following the evidence those are the
right guiding principles
and i have to say it's a welcome change
from some of the language the prime
minister's used
in the past and i urge the prime
minister now to stick to that
turning to the substance of the matter
first
schools we all agree that the priority
must be for
all children to be back in school as
quickly as possible
and to stay in school we want that to
happen
on march the 8th as the government has
promised
confidence of parents teachers and
school staff will be critical
so can the prime minister please confirm
that the chief medical officer and the
chief scientific
officer support the full reopening of
all schools on march the 8th
and will he commit to publishing all the
relevant medical evidence on this
issue can the prime minister also
indicate what the government is doing to
overcome the huge logistical challenges
this presents the prime minister touched
on mass testing
in his statement but there was nothing
on nightingale classrooms and extra
capacity
this is a huge problem particularly for
schools with smaller buildings
so can the prime minister update the
house on how he's going to deal
with this in just over two weeks time
let me turn to a linked issue within
weeks of schools returning last autumn
thousands of teachers and school staff
were self-isolating
causing huge disruption to the running
of schools
and children's learning we don't want
that again
that's why we called for the early
vaccination of all teachers and school
staff
in my own constituency the fantastic
crick institute
which has been doing amazing work has
been vaccinating hundreds of people a
day
they've been very clear to me and and
publicly
that they could be doing more and it's
obvious to me that over one weekend
they could have vaccinated all teachers
and school staff in camden
if they'd been allowed to do so and
without bumping anyone else from
priority list
there are similar examples across the
country so will the premise to see what
more can be done
to speed up the vaccination of teachers
and school staff
to ensure that children young people not
only return to school on march the 8th
but stay in school having returned
let me turn into isolation support as we
release
health measures however gradually
there's a risk that infection rates will
go up the prime minister
made that clear in his statement
therefore it's
more important than ever that test trace
and isolate
is working and working well one of the
most concerning figures in a recent sage
report
is that only three in ten people who
should be self-isolating
are actually doing so and it's obvious
that one of the main drivers of this
is insecurity at work as the chair of
test and tracer said
people are scared to take the test
because they can't afford to
self-isolate
that not only harms our health response
it costs the economy too and it's got to
be fixed
we've proposed that the 500 pound
isolation payment
which is currently only available to one
in eight workers
be made available to everyone who needs
it
will the prime minister consider that
because if we don't
shift the three in ten figure there'll
be a huge hole
in our defenses third mr speaker
economic support
the prime minister announced a roadmap
today
but it won't have escaped businesses
that many of them will not be able to
open until
mid-april at the earliest and and many
until mid-june
i'm not questioning the health basis for
that decision which i support
but i am reiterating what we've always
said that health restrictions
must be accompanied by proper economic
support
and it makes no sense to announce today
that businesses will be closed
for many more weeks or months without
announcing new economic support
at the same time the prime minister says
well
the budget will be next week but there's
nothing stopping him saying
today that business rates relief will be
extended
that furlough will be extended or that
the
v.a.t cup for hospitality and leisure
will also be
extended businesses are crying out for
that certainty
and the prime minister should give it to
them today
the prime minister should also announce
proper support for the three million
self-employed who've been left out of
all support for the last
year this morning on lbc i was asked
about this again
by a self-employed business woman who's
at a wits end at the lack of government
support
this road map means that she may not be
able to get
up and running again in her business
until mid-june
so surely the prime minister needs to
act now to close the gaps for these
three million
mr speaker we support the twin
principles that prime minister has set
out today
the lifting of restrictions must be both
cautious and irreversible
but i know the prime minister will come
under pressure from those on his own
benches
to go faster and to throw caution to the
wind
last week it was reported that around 60
years old members of parliament
called for the end of all restrictions
by the end of april
i'm sure they're going to be similar
calls this afternoon
i hope the prime minister takes the
opportunity to face this down
because if this road map is to work he
needs to listen to the chief scientific
officer and the chief medical officer
not the honourable members for wickham
or the forest of dean
if the prime minister does he
if the prime minister does he will have
our support
and will secure a majority in the house
if he does not
we will waste all the sacrifices of the
last 12 months
thank you mr speaker uh well i am
very grateful to the right honorable
gentleman uh for his
overall uh support for the uh the road
map and indeed i welcome his support for
the
for the vaccine rollout and uh and i'm
sure that many people will be glad to
hear what he's
he says that i uh can't uh the help but
reminding you mr speaker that the right
honourable gentleman did vote
uh to stay in the european uh medicines
agency which would have made the
uh a vaccine roll out at this speed uh
impossible
mr speaker and he's right to uh to say
that
uh it's a priority to get schools uh
back safely and i'm delighted that he
agrees
with that and i can certainly say that
that plan for march the 8th for all
schools back on march the 8th is
is supported by the chief medical
officer and the chief scientific
advisor and it would be a good thing if
he could perhaps persuade
uh some of his friends in the in the
unions uh
to to say so as well uh mr speaker and
finally
uh to say that schools are are safe he
he mentions
uh self-isolation the importance of
self-isolation we will continue
uh to support those who are asked to
self-isolate and indeed increase our
our package of of of support for them
uh as for support for for business for
for the self-employed uh which he he
rightly
raises we will continue uh to put our
arms around
uh businesses and uh livelihoods around
the
uh countries we have done throughout the
pandemic and
the chancellor who has been extremely
creative uh in this respect
will be setting out the details in the
budget next week as
as he would expect mr speaker overall uh
i think it is i think we can safely say
that uh we've had
cautious support from the leader of the
opera
of the opposition today the bitter
experience has taught me that his
support is very far
from irreversible uh mr speaker who
knows
uh what he will be saying uh next week
but i'm i'm glad of it today
theresa may thank you mr speaker i refer
the house to my entry in the members
register
can i say to my right honourable friend
that i welcome his statement today i
particularly welcome
the return to schools on march the 8th
but there's another sector
which is important for jobs in my
constituency which is fundamental to our
economy
and critical for global britain the
aviation sector
he says there's going to be a task force
report by the 12th of april so people
can plan for the summer
that won't allow people to plan at every
stage the government has taken weeks
from these reports to actually provide
certainty to the industry
the industry needs three months
preparation
from the point of certainty so i ask my
right honourable friend
to look again at this timetable for that
task force report to bring it forward
so we can open up our international air
travel and make sure that britain is
open for business
i'm grateful to my right honourable
friend and she uh is quite rightly mr
speaker
deity campaigner for the aviation uh
industry uh and uh all it brings to our
to our country and uh what i can tell
her
is that uh we will continue to support
that industry throughout these difficult
times
but i believe that setting a deadline of
april the 12th uh for the report
of the travel task force the newly
formed uh reconstituted travel task
force
will give people time to
make their plans for the summer and if
things go uh well mr speaker if we can
uh if we can meet those uh these uh
not before uh dates then i do believe uh
there is every chance of an aviation
recovery later on this year let's head
to the leader of the smp with ian
blackford ian blackford
and thank you mr speaker the success of
the vaccine rollout led by our
incredible nhs staff is something
to behold and something that we are all
thankful for for the first time in many
months people across these islands
are genuinely hopeful that an end to the
current level of lockdown is finally in
sight
but people also know that there is one
major threat that could undo
much of this whole the spread of new
international variants of this virus now
poses the single biggest threat
to finally getting out of this pandemic
that is why quarantine measures for
international arrivals is so important
we simply can't afford to get this wrong
and that is why the scottish government
has taken tough but
absolutely necessary action those
arriving in scotland on an international
flight
have to quarantine in a hotel for 10
days
in england though the policy only
applies to people traveling from
red less countries but mr speaker
the evidence shows that people across
the united kingdom
are demanding stronger measures to
prevent the threat of any new variant
yougov polling last week showed that
only 18 support the uk government's
rules and quarantine were a massive 72
percent
of people across the united kingdom
prefer the scottish government's
comprehensive approach
prime minister your plan to end lockdown
will be worthless
if your insufficient quarantine measures
allow a new variant
in through the back door people right
across the united kingdom are continuing
to make huge sacrifices
children are not yet physically at
school families are isolated that is a
loneliness
epidemic people are really struggling
and this can't
be all for nothing do not leave the back
door open
do not risk all the hard work all the
sacrifices
that have been made given all that is at
stake
can you explain why the uk government is
failing to introduce the strong
quarantine measures
that the public across the united
kingdom are demanding
will the prime ministers think again and
introduce the scottish government's
comprehensive approach
for international travels let us all do
what we need to in order to drive down
the spread of the virus
to get us all to a position where we can
reverse lock down
and begin to restore social interaction
for our well-being
mr speaker we have amongst the toughest
quarantine measures anywhere in the
world
as as the right honorable gentleman well
knows uh in
including the the mandatory uh
of incarceration in hotels appointed
uh by the government if you return from
one of the uh
the 33 red list uh countries as he well
knows
and we will continue uh to impose very
very tough
uh controls on people coming into this
country uh he should also know
uh that the uh new variants
are we are confident that all our
vaccines are effective in reducing
death and serious disease and we have no
reason to doubt
uh that they are effective in reducing
death and serious disease
uh with the new variants as well uh mr
speaker and
he should also know that over the course
the next few months we will see
new uh vaccines uh to defeat these
uh vaccine escaping variants and that is
something that is
uh being uh that is evolving the whole
time other than that
mr speaker i i was delighted by the by
the unaccustomed note
of optimism uh with which the right
honourable gentleman
began he isn't often notable for his
optimism uh in
uh in this in this house he's rolling
his eyes mr speaker
uh but i think i rather liked it when he
began with oxford i think he should
stick to it i think it suits him
more optimism i think from the right
honourable gentleman would be
uh would be i think nice to hear
let's head to the chair of the select
committee with jeremy hum jeremy hunt
mr speaker talking of optimism the prime
minister approach feels very similar to
harold wilson who said he was an
optimist but one who always carried a
raincoat
and his caution is absolutely right in
the face of these
new variants when we are potentially so
close
to the finishing line but as we get
there
will he recognize the brilliant work of
our health and care staff
by building back better for them
potentially in next week's budget
by announcing that we will finally make
sure that we're training enough
doctors and nurses with a long-term
workforce plan
and giving the social care sector a
10-year plan
just as we gave the nhs 10 years ago
yes indeed mr speaker i pay tribute
again as as i have many times before to
the incredible work
not just of our nhs staff but of our our
social care staff who've
uh really borne the brunt of the of the
pandemic and
have done uh fantastically well and uh
we will certainly be bringing forward
uh reforms of social care in addition uh
to the the massive investments that
we've already made
let's head to ed davey davey
mr speaker the road map to recovery must
put people
hit hardest by this pandemic first not
least people with
learning disabilities they have died at
rates
more than three and a half times the
rest of the population
yet many are still not being prioritized
for vaccination
joe wiley has spoken powerfully about
how hideously unfair it was to be
offered the vaccine
before her sister francis who is now in
hospital with covid
after an outbreak in her care home and i
know many other carers across the
country
feel the same while our loved ones
remain so vulnerable to this virus
so will the prime minister tell us when
on his roadmap everyone with a learning
disability
will have been offered their first jab
the uh brand normal gentleman is
entirely right to draw attention to the
particular uh suffering
endured by vulnerable groups throughout
this pandemic and that's why
those with learning disabilities those
with particular vulnerabilities
uh do appear high up in the in the jcvi
priority list which is i'm sure exactly
what he would expect
let's said to ian sir ian duncan smith
sarian
mr speaker first of all can i
congratulate my prime minister for
his incredible bold decision last year
it's due to that in getting the vaccines
rollout going on that we are now looking
at the eventual end to this coveted
nightmare so he deserves all the
plaudits he gets for that and more
but i agree with his caution in this
rollout uh
and going back to i've been unlocked but
i just
say that the hospitality sector to my
writable friend
is the biggest a very big employer of
the poorest in society and it is them
who have suffered the most in incomes
and
nearly half of those businesses are
talking about closing
i just wonder whether the prime minister
would feel it possible
to be able to review again the nature of
opening up
inside those restaurants and pubs and
checking that there is no
uh real risk beyond any of the other
elements that he's opening up
and if that is the case to take that
bold decision
as and when the data dictates it prime
minister
i completely i thank my right on the
phone for what he said just now
and uh i i totally understand
uh where he's coming from and the the
urgency of those in the hospitality
sector who want to
uh to open up as as soon as possible as
indeed we all do everybody in this house
wants that uh to happen uh but we we
also understand
the risk of a of another surge and and
the consequent risk of
of another of a fourth lockdown mr
speaker which i i don't think anybody
wants to see
least of all the businesses concerned
and what we have in this roadmap
are our dates uh admittedly
uh they are not before dates but there
are dates to which
businesses can now work april the 12th
for outdoor
hospitality uh may the 17th uh for
indoor
hospitality that gives uh at least some
certainty mr speaker and i think in this
very very difficult time
with these difficult trade-offs i think
people would be prepared
to trade uh some urgency in some haste
for more certainty and more reliability
and that is what
we aim to give let's head to lid savile
roberts
let's supple robots
workers across the uk still face a
hopeless choice
self-isolating and suffering loss of
earnings or going to work with a risk
spreading the virus
now eight months ago i raised this very
problem of the uk's unfit sick pay
system with the prime minister
but there are still people in work who
cannot afford to self-isolate
ahead of the budget will the prime
minister commit to raising
and expanding statutory sick pay once
and for all as a key
long-term lesson to be learnt from this
pandemic or is he content for our
poorest communities
to be bited by ill health now and quite
possibly again in future
prime minister uh mr speaker i i i thank
the
lady we and repeat the points i've made
to her many times
uh before but i'm grateful to her for
raising them again uh
we uh will continue to uh
look after people uh throughout the
pandemic we've increased
uh benefits as the uh the payment of 500
pounds uh mr speaker and other
uh payments that we'll uh make available
and our undertaking is to make sure
that we protect people whether they're
self-isolating or whether they're
forced uh not to be able to work
throughout the duration of the pandemic
and you'll be hearing more about that
from the chancellor on on march the 3rd
dr julian lewis
thankfully my right honourable friend
has clearly stated today
that an extreme zero covered approach
is impracticable can he confirm
that most if not all of his key
scientific
advisers now accept that our strategic
goal must be and is a practical
vaccine-based method of controlling
covid like any other serious
respiratory virus such as influenza
my my right honourable friend is is
completely right in the analogy he draws
and the only
reason i'm able to say mr speaker to the
country
uh is that we must learn to live with uh
kovid as we
live with uh flu mr speaker in the long
term
is of course because we have this
vaccination program
and the capability to evolve our
vaccines
let's head south to caroline lucas
caroline lucas
thank you mr speaker as well as
welcoming the success of the vaccination
program
i want to emphasize there is a lack of
sufficient financial support for
self-isolation
there is in the words of one of the
government's own advisors
a huge gaping hole in the prime
minister's coveted strategy
the payments aren't enough they're not
reaching the right people
so as well as fixing that once and for
all will he
also take this opportunity to respond
with the seriousness it deserves
to the high court's ruling on friday
that the secretary of state
acted unlawfully by failing to publish
coveted contracts
no one has ever suggested that ministers
didn't need to act fast to procure ppe
and other covert related contracts but
transparency
matters even in a crisis so if the
government has nothing to hide will he
now publish details
of who benefited from the vip lane who
lifted the velvet ropes for those
favored companies
what price were they paid and why were
they chosen
parliament and the country have a right
to know
mr speaker of course we'll continue to
look after uh those who are self
isolating and to
to improve their support where we can as
i said as for the
as for the contracts that she has uh
just mentioned
uh all of the details uh are on
uh the record and of course it was right
to work as fast as we possibly could uh
to get the ppe
that this country so desperately needed
i said no
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
the medics and volunteers who worked so
hard in providing covered 19 vaccines
across the kingdom
in the wakefield ccg area alone more
than 87 000 vaccines have been
administered
the vaccine rollout is the fundamental
rule out
ensuring that we are able to return to
now lamented normality
and properly follow the pathway pathway
outlined by the prime minister just now
mr speaker i'm concerned that vaccine
disinformation has specifically targeted
ethnic minority groups
leading to some refusing the vaccine
when offered can my right on
friend the prime minister outline what
steps the government is taking
to encourage bain groups to receive the
vaccine when offered
prime minister well i'm grateful to my
my honorable friend i congratulate him
on the spectacular throne in which he
appears to be uh sitting
mr speaker but he and i uh not so long
ago
uh were were together in the out in the
our hikma uh community center in
in badly and i uh again thank my uh
thank all
all those involved and indeed community
groups up and down the land who did an
outstanding job
in promulgating uh vaccinations uh he
raises a very very important point i
thank him
for what he's doing to promote
vaccinations for everybody
let's go over to jeremy corbyn jeremy
corbyn
thank you thank you very much mr speaker
my constituents are seeking explanations
most of them have lost income many have
lost their jobs
all are facing varying degrees of stress
from the very severe
to the concern about their lives many
local small businesses
have closed for good because they see no
future
and they're not getting the support that
they need yet mr speaker i think answers
are required from the prime minister
how 10.5 billion pounds of nhs contracts
were awarded without tender however
further 99
of all nhs contracts were awarded again
without
tender and that last week the court
found
that the secretary of state for health
had not acted legally
in the awarding of these contracts and
so
i ask the prime minister to do two
things
will he end this scandalous
privatization
of our nhs which is happening before our
very eyes
and will he also replace the health
secretary with somebody
who will stand by and obey the law and
publish
in advance all contracts that are due to
be led
so the public can see how their money is
being spent
um well mr speaker the best of my
memory the uh the labour party
opposition
uh were advocating during the uh earlier
stages of the crisis that we should
secure ppe
from i think a theatrical impresario uh
who specialized in capes and
and gowns and a football agent who
claimed to be able to get a hold of of
masks mr speaker
uh we went as as fast as we possibly uh
could
to get uh ppe and those uh who are now
uh denouncing us for going uh too fast
were those who were complaining
uh back then that we weren't going fast
enough said to david simmons
david simmons mr speaker my
righteous friend and the government have
rightly been unapologetic
throughout this pandemic in
determination to safeguard children's
educational opportunities
and well-being can the prime minister
confirm
that once all schools reopen on the 8th
of march
the government will be putting in place
all the measures necessary
to keep them open working with academy
trusts and crucially local authorities
to avoid any further disruption to our
children's education
prime minister yes indeed mr speaker i'm
grateful to my honourable friend because
that is in that is exactly why uh we
wish to
take this cautious uh but irreversible
uh
approach in order to make sure that we
don't have to go back into measures that
would
uh keep kids out of school again and
he's quite right in what he says
let's head over to jim shannon jim
shannon
thank you mr speaker can i uh welcome
the prime minister and government's
progressive road map which of course is
underpinned
by the incredibly successful rule out of
the vaccine
and can the prime minister confirm that
we have no
supply issues on our own target to give
the second dose
to all of those on the nhs front line
who will do their second dose within the
next few weeks
and can the prime minister assure us
that this will not adversely affect the
continued supply
and the availability of first vaccines
for informal carers of those
who are shielded thank you prime
minister
mr speaker the honourable drummer is
completely right
uh to uh to raise this and we and to
care deeply about supply
uh we have no supply issues at the
moment uh and we're confident that we
can meet
our targets i said to sabana jenkins sir
bernard
thank you mr speaker um may i
congratulate the prime minister
on the fact that there are sunlit
uplands that now beckon us
but that he's right to say that the
threat remains substantial because while
we're unlocking
uh at this stage only a third of the
adult population has been
vaccinated so what will be the
government be doing
to minimize the threat of another
lockdown such as
strengthening the track and trace and
isolate operations particularly at local
level
providing coveted safe spaces so it's
easier for people to
self-isolate who are infected and to
deploy testing capacity
more effectively such as for example
testing school
children twice a week in schools as
we're already going to be testing
teachers
prime minister my right normal friend is
absolutely right in the
the ideas that he he puts forward uh
i would that test track and trace has
been improving the uh the whole time
over the
uh the period of the pandemic and uh
he's right to draw attention to the
potential of lateral flow testing not
just in schools whereas he says we're
going to be doing it twice a week for
secondary school pupils
uh after the first uh a couple of weeks
uh but uh also uh rolling it out for
companies for
uh for uh local areas local communities
to take it up
as an additional support and additional
way
of fighting the disease let's head to
ruth jones
ruth jones thank you mr speaker
i know the prime minister was in my
right honourable friend's constituency
of turbine last week to see the vaccine
program being rolled out by the
inaugural bevin university health board
at cumbrian stadium so i joined with him
in thanking all the welsh nhs staff and
volunteers
who are working so hard to save lives by
rolling up the vaccine program in this
way however i wonder if the prime
minister agrees with me
and many people across newport west who
believe that every single penny of
public money
must be accounted for and if so what's
he going to say to his health secretary
who according to the course breached his
legal obligation
by not publishing details within 30 days
of contracts being signed
we've had two attempts at getting the
prime minister to answer so i'm hoping
it's third time lucky
prime minister mr speaker i'm going to
ruthlessly to repeat
uh what uh i said uh before which is
that i believe that it was absolutely
right for this country to secure
uh ppe as fast as we uh as we possibly
could and
as a justice has been right to roll out
a vaccine
program as fast as we possibly can and
it was great to be in
uh in qumran and and to see what they're
they're doing there and
and that is thanks to the the dynamic
work of the
uh of the nhs uh and and indeed of
everybody in the department of health
and social care including the health
secretary
up to mark logan mark logan
prime minister today i hosted a zoom
between
bolton north east pubs restaurants and
the minister for small businesses
can the prime minister ensure we allow
businesses enough time
to improve our hospitality's operating
data
and make the dates in 2021 utterly
delectable prime minister
uh i i thank my honorable friend for
for what he's doing to help local
business and to
and to rally them and i would just say
to them that if we can
stick to this road map and i believe
that we can then there is not long
to go now for those uh businesses there
are there are
there are for hospitality in in bolton
there are two dates there's outdoor
hospitality on april the 12th and then
indoor with all its potential
on may the 17th i do believe those that
gives
some uh some dates for us all to think
about for business
to work towards and i hope that will be
of some reassurance to them
thank you mr speaker some eminent
members of sage
have indicated that they're concerned
about a resurgence with the return of
children to schools
so can the prime minister say whether
the
chief medical officer and the chief
scientific officer
support reopening schools in their
entirety
on the 8th of march because
during the last term many schools
suffered an enormous amount of
disruption because staff were off
isolated and is it the best way to
prevent that happening in the future to
ensure that all school staff are
vaccinated
prime minister i have a a deal of
respect for the
honourable gentleman since he and i have
clashed many times
over issues in in london but i think he
uncommonly showed a failure to follow
what uh
i i'd already said in my answer uh to
the right honourable gentleman that the
cmo and the csa
uh both approve of uh of reopening in
full
we now go down to andrew griffith
underground
thank you mr speaker more than anything
the nation's businesses need
certainty in order to plan today's
roadmap provides that certainty
and reopening schools is a welcome and
critical element within it
does the prime minister agree that like
navigating lock gates on a canal
it's important we now proceed
sequentially as fast as possible
but always in a forward direction
prime minister hey mr speaker has
anybody who steered a
a narrow boat or a canal boat well barge
will know
in a canal the important thing is not to
oversteer
one way and then be forced to uh to
correct and
bump the sides of the canal uh as as you
go and that's what we're trying to
avoid mr speaker that's why we're
embarking on a
a cautious but irreversible approach
let's head up to debbie abraham's debbie
abrahams
thank you mr speaker mr speaker i will
leave till
uh another time to ask the prime
minister why
we didn't have adequate uh ppe stocks
given
exercise 16 exercise cygnus in 2016
stipulated we need to increase our our
pp stockpiles
but i was really concerned about the
health secretary's tone on the media
round yesterday where he
seemed to infer that he'd done nothing
wrong and the
judge was actually the one that was
making mistake this is not how a healthy
democracy
works so i repeat the questions of my
honourable friend
the member for brighton pavilion will he
publish
all outstanding contracts because there
are outstanding contracts that have not
been published
bring an end to the emergency
procurement powers and reintroduce a
tendering process
prime minister mr speaker i really
can i can see that there's a concerted
attempt to make a point here today
about this but i i must say that i i do
think that
uh every effort was made by the
government
uh to secure uh ppe as fast as we
possibly
could and i think that's what the people
of this country wanted we ended up
i think with 32 billion items of pp and
we now have the capability which i think
will
reassure uh her constituents more than
anything else they have the capability
now
in this country thanks to lord dayton
and the ppe task force and others
to make 70 percent of our ppe needs in
this country
let's head to craig whitchika craig
whitchika
thank you mr speaker it is brilliant
news that we've vaccinated one in three
adults now in the uk a huge testament to
british science the nhs
my rhino normal friend the member for
west suffolk and his whole team
and everybody involved in the
vaccination program not least
my right honourable friend the prime
minister but does the prime minister
agree with me
that because of his swift rollout of the
vaccine
program we're in a much stronger
position now to start easing
restrictions
and putting us back on the path to some
form of normality
much sooner than would have been without
a vaccination
rollout program prime minister
yes of course mr speaker my honourable
friend is completely right and i thank
him
very much for what he has just said the
uh
the only reason uh this road map is
possible and uh we're one of a
tiny number of countries around the
world that have been able to set out
a a road map with uh dates and
milestones this far ahead
uh mr speaker it's only possible because
of the vaccination rollout program
let's head to neil coyle neil coyle
thank you mr speaker and people of this
country have endured so much in the last
year including personal tragedies
amongst the highest excess death toll
job losses under the worst damage to any
major economy but they've also seen the
prime minister's closest advisor dominic
cummings break the covered regulations
the home secretary break the municipal
code
and now the health secretary break the
laws are high prone contracts all
without consequences
going forward prime minister uh will you
end
the system of one rule for your tory
powers and another for the rest of us
prime minister uh mr speaker i think
contained within that uh question was a
uh possibly another suggestion that we
could have done
things differently with the procurement
of of pp all i will say is the contracts
are there on the
on the record for everybody to see and i
think most people in this country will
understand
that in very difficult if not desperate
times uh last spring
we had to work as fast as we possibly
could thank you mr speaker i welcome the
prime minister's statement especially on
schools
he's right to be driven by the evidence
professor mark woolhouse
told the science and technology
committee uh last week
that during the whole year and i quote
there has been very very little evidence
of any transmission outdoors happening
in the uk so will my right honourable
friend continue to look at the evidence
and see whether it's possible to bring
back outdoor activities
uh like sports uh during the weeks ahead
i know with the spring weather coming
that would be a great boon to millions
of people across the country
yeah the prime minister of of course
he's right to
raise the point about outdoor
transmission and that's why
uh on uh march the 8th with the return
of schools uh
we're also going to be seeing uh school
sport which is which is great
uh plus uh outdoor recreation one-on-one
in the way that i described
earlier on mr speaker and then on march
the 29th it's the rule of six
plus two households uh together plus
more sport
outdoors uh mr speaker of all kinds
uh up to it including uh i think rugby
with tackling but without the scrums
uh mr speaker as i understand uh the the
guidance
right let's go to ellen doran's alan
doran's
thank you mr speaker and good afternoon
analysis by the royal college of gps of
nhs
england's coveted 19 vaccination figures
show that people of black authenticity
are half as likely as people of white
ethnicity to get vaccinated
and people of easy and authenticity are
under two-thirds as lightly as a white
counterpart to accept vaccination
what additional specific steps will the
prime minister take to encourage greater
uptake of the vaccines in these
communities
prime minister mr speaker the
uh number uh of people receiving the
vaccine is actually
increasing in all communities on roughly
the same uh gradient but we're concerned
he's quite right to raise the
the concern that i think everybody has
about uptake in
in some communities it is now going
faster and what we've done
is uh uh rolled out a network of of
community champions
uh i think we've put about 23 million
pounds into supporting community
champions
uh for uh hard to reach our vaccine
resistant
uh communities now just the most
important thing is for everybody to get
across the message that
the vaccine is a wonderful thing
everybody should get it get your vaccine
when you get your message from the nhs
it's a great brain thank you uh mr
speaker can i welcome very strongly the
reopening
of schools after what we've put them
through over the last year it's time we
prioritize
the interests of our children and young
people the prime minister
also sets out a program based on data
not dates and that must be right but
will he please publish the precise
criteria
for each of those stages to be met and
finally
when the renewal of emergency powers is
due
will he undertake to bring that vote to
the house before
the easter recess and not after yeah
prime minister
yes indeed mr speaker there's going to
be a massive i think data dump is the
word i
uh i've been uh i've been quoted uh
today so colleagues may already have
seen some of the data that's uh that's
available
uh underpinning the the road map that
we've set out and there will of course
be
another vote in this house about these
uh measures before
uh easter and then uh those measures in
turn
uh mr speaker uh elapse on on june the
21st in the way that i've described
let's head to rachel hopkins rachel
thank you mr speaker local council
public health teams will continue to be
pivotal
pivotal in controlling the virus but the
government's decade of austerity and
cuts has damaged their capacity
with the public health grant last year
2020 21
being 22 percent lower per head in real
terms
compared to 2015-16 so will the prime
minister tell the house
when the public health grant allocation
for this year will be announced
and whether it will include a
significant real terms increase
to ensure councils can continue to keep
our communities safe
prime minister madam deputy speaker um
i'm very grateful to councils and
particularly
public health officials for the
incredible work they've done uh in the
last year
absolutely amazing uh work that they
have they have done
uh we are supporting them with another
4.7 billion pounds
as she knows uh to support local
councils in everything they
they do and we will continue to offer
support throughout the pandemic
now go to peter alders
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
before his statement and for the
precautionary approach that he is
pursuing
to lifting the lot it is clear
that the impact of covid will be the
time
and i would thus be most grateful if he
could confirm
this plan is coordinated and
synchronized
with the measures that the chancellor
now will announce in the budget
and there will be ongoing support for
both
badly affected businesses sectors such
as hospitality
and for those people who are relying on
the 20 pound
uplift to universal credit prime
minister
thank you madam deputy speaker yes of
course uh
mr speaker i'm a man of mexico we will
make sure
that we continue to look after uh people
throughout the the pandemic
uh as we have done uh since the
beginning
and uh the chancellor will be setting
out uh exactly what we're doing next
week
we now go to andrew quinn
it's been under local restrictions since
the end of july and it's been a long
few months so can i welcome the road map
out of lockdown
and also the success of the vaccine now
somebody who's just been
just about shaken off long coveted
symptoms 11 months after contracting
covid can i urge him not to forget those
still struggling
and the many more who will develop long
covid as a consequence of the
latest wave of the virus as the economy
switches back on as
lives return to normal will he also
commit to do more for those
who still don't have access to
long-covered clinics who still don't
have access to support or help
so that nobody is left behind prime
minister uh
mrs mcmahon i'm delighted to see
uh the honourable gentleman back on
fighting form uh somebody who's
enjoyed lively on-screen debates with
him
uh in the past it's good to see him uh
back in back in shape he's right to draw
attention to
uh long-term uh consequences of the uh
of the disease and
uh we will do everything we can uh to
alleviate suffering
uh and and and to continue uh to invest
in support for those who need it
mark harper thank you very much madam
deputy speaker
can i first of all thank the prime
minister for the measures to get our
children back to school on
march 8th that's very welcome and
something we've called for
and i think he should be congratulated
on that and also for the speed of the
vaccine
rollout could i just press him a little
on the the thoughts behind
vaccinating groups one to nine so that's
everyone over 50
and those 16 to 64 with a health
condition that makes them vulnerable to
covid
those groups account for 99 of deaths
and around 80 percent of hospitalization
so
for what reason once they've been
vaccinated and protected
from covid uh by the end of april
at the latest are is there any need for
restrictions to continue
prime minister he he makes an excellent
uh my own friend makes an excellent
point the the
difficulty is that of course there will
be at least
a significant minority uh who either
have
not uh taken up the vaccine of those in
those vulnerable groups for the reasons
that the house has been
uh discussing or who having uh had the
vaccine are not
uh given sufficient uh protection as
though we believe that the protection is
very substantial
but there will be a a large minority who
will not have sufficient
protection and the risk is that if you
let the brakes off
madam deputy speaker then the the
disease could surge up in such a way
as again uh to rip through
uh a large number of uh of
the rip through those groups in a way
that uh alas
i don't think anybody in this country
would want to see so it's a i'm afraid
it's it's
it's pure uh mathematics there is still
a substantial
body of risk and we also need
uh to wait and see exactly
uh what the effects of the the vaccine
are there are some promising
data but i think what the country would
want at this stage
is uh caution uncertainty and
irreversibility and that is what we aim
to provide we now go to barbara keely
thank you madame destiny speaker
throughout this crisis the government
has been
slow to offer the financial support that
people need
from three million people excluded from
any support
to thousands of people failing to
self-isolate because they can't afford
to miss work
it's clear we need to do more to get
through the next few months can the
prime minister confirm that the budget
will bring
forward adequate financial support for
everyone who cannot work due to the
pandemic
including those who are self-isolating
rather than the current system which
sees too many people
fall through the cracks prime minister
yes i certainly can confirm that and she
should wait to see what
uh the chancellor uh has to say next
week and i think colleagues on all sides
of the house
uh would concede that the uh the
programmes and support that
uh the chuck my writer and friend the
chancellor has brought forward uh have
been extremely effective
and uh and generous by
by virtually all international
comparisons
hugh merriman thank you very much madam
deputy speaker and can i welcome the
prime minister's statement
those of us who represent constituencies
where retail hospitality
and tourism is an absolute lifeblood
will really welcome the dates and the
fact that
domestic holidays in england are open as
normal for the summer but could i ask
the prime minister just to give a little
more
detail on the global travel task force
which reports by 12th of april
and that it will set out the
requirements regarding testing
vaccination certificates social
distancing and face
masks and i hope an end towards
quarantine
yes prime minister uh yes indeed uh uh
uh madam deputy speaker the travel task
force will be looking at all those
things
uh quarantine destinations and so on and
and so forth i think at the moment uh
one consideration is that
uh we need to make sure that there are
uh countries that will be
uh willing to accept uh british tourists
in the way that we would
uh like to see some of them have stepped
forward and said that they will but uh
they're currently not very numerous
uh we now go to emma hardy emma hardy
thank you madam deputy speaker lateral
flow testing is central to the prime
minister's educational reopening plans
so can he explain why our only real
world published figures from the student
asymptomatic testing program in scotland
before christmas
showed almost 30 percent of positive
tests turned out to be false
when subject to a confirmatory pcr
considering the financial educational
and mental health
impact of self-isolation does the prime
minister share my concerns
that a lot of students are going to be
told to self-isolate for no reason
prime minister i don't recognize that
that figure
madam deputy speaker and uh lateral flow
tests are extremely valuable
in isolating uh asymptomatic
uh positive tests and in helping schools
to
to restart and that's why we're pursuing
them
we now go to suzanne webb suzanne webb
thank you madam deputy speaker i welcome
the statement today
and the prudent and cautious measures to
reducing lockdown restrictions
we have all had our role to play in
combating this virus and a role which
will continue for some time
so with the prime minister join me in in
saying thank you to all my constituents
in starbridge for their continued
patience
and resilience to the fabulous dudley
nhs to my care homes
mary stephens hospice to all those
unsung heroes to my teaching fraternity
the army of vaccinators to all key
workers and those essential workers who
have kept us fed
and watered all truly heroic efforts by
one
and all prime minister well i
congratulate my honorable friend on her
brilliant question i
i i plant my flag firmly on everything
that she's
just said and echo it uh cincinnati i i
add my
thanks uh not just to the people of
starbridge for their patience and
resilience but to the people of the
entire country
now going to manila wilson manila wilson
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
too often children and young people have
been an
afterthought during this pandemic aside
from lost learning
many children are feeling anxious and
lonely due to not seeing their friends
missing out on play and other activities
we know one in four has self-harmed in
the past year eating rate disorder
eating disorder rates are soaring and
demand for acute beds
is reaching crisis point so will the
prime minister
please commit to providing a ring fence
resilience fund for schools
as proposed by young minds to ensure
that young people are given the mental
health
support that they so desperately need
prime minister she's absolutely right
uh to draw attention to uh the uh
endurance the that uh the things that
we've asked young people to put up with
this
uh year over the last 12 months i can't
have been a generation
like it that's experienced so much
disruption to their education and
she's right to call attention to the
pressures the stress
that that has caused and so we've
invested massively
in uh in mental health provision
provision particularly for young
people's
mental health and one of the things
we've done is appoint a young people's
mental health
ambassador in the form of of alex george
but the top
priority for the government is now
not just to get kids back in school on
march the 8th
but to make sure that we remediate their
education uh with a
program uh much more than a billion
pounds and
uh the secretary of state for uh
education will be setting out more
about our our plans to help those those
pupils
uh later this week now to sarah
dines sarah dines
thank you madam deputy speaker the
people of the country are desperate to
be set free as soon as possible
as my right honourable friend knows many
of the tourism and hospitality
businesses in derbyshire dales
have been hit heavily by this pandemic
can he please encourage the country
to book self-catered self-contained
accommodation for staycation holidays
in places such as starbucks adele's this
summer where families are able to
minimize mixing with other people
but to have some fun
prime minister oh uh she's
completely right and as you would have
heard just now
the option uh to book a a staycation all
being well
uh madam deputy speaker is now there for
april the
12th and uh i can't imagine there are
many destinations lovelier
around then than the derbyshire dales
now go to neil hanvey neil hanvey
thank you madam deputy speaker following
the high court ruling that the secretary
of state for health and social care
acted unlawfully by failing to comply
with transparency rules
while the prime minister now published
the names of the companies
awarded contracts that were introduced
to high priority lanes
by ministers honourable members peers
and officials
and set out any material financial or
fiduciary
responsibility or relationship between
each company and the persons responsible
for that introduction to the priority
line
prime minister yeah uh i'm grateful
uh deputy speaker repeat the answer i've
given several times uh
with all these contracts uh uh published
in the in the normal way
can i go to robert neil so robert neal
thank you madam deputy speaker welcome
to the prime minister's statement
and we all recognize the huge work
that's been done to make the vaccine
roll out a success
but can i press him upon why some of
the dates are set as no earlier then if
we believe in the vaccine
we believe in the program and we believe
in the data
isn't the logic that if the data shows
we can move to free up sectors of the
economy sooner we should not
artificially hold them back
surely that's following the data
shouldn't there be a little more
flexibility there
prime minister uh mr speaker
we need to see uh the the madame deputy
speak we need to see
uh the data we need to see the effect of
each successive
relaxation and as i explained uh to the
house
uh we need to we need four weeks to
assess
uh whether or not the relaxation has
caused a surge in the
in the virus because that's the time it
uh it takes so from the unlocking of
uh of the opening of schools uh until
the 12th of april we'll need to assess
that then we'll need a further
a week to give people due notice in the
same uh and the same onward through
may the 17th june the 21st uh and
and so on and the the reason
for that cautious but irreversible
approach
is that i think people would rather have
uh certainty rather than
urgency and uh we can we're going as
as fast as we reasonably and responsibly
can
but if it's a trade-off between haste
and
uncertainty i think people would prefer
certainty
now going to tracy braven tracy braven
thank you madam deputy speaker the prime
minister will appreciate parts of my
constituency
and others in west yorkshire have been
in heightened restrictions
and higher tiers since last summer when
others had much more freedoms
our people and businesses have paid a
disproportionately high price
in the national effort to tackle covid
and because of this
many areas are building back from a more
challenging position
so can the prime minister confirm today
that funding packages will address
this specific inequality and that there
will be no return to regional tears
ensuring our recovery from coved is
truly
a national recovery prime minister
yes you should wait to see what the
chancellor says next week and uh
we will make sure that uh we go forward
uh as a
as a one nation together william
madame deputy could i um congratulate
all of the staff and volunteers
particularly at the boston moor and
often in my constituency where i had the
privilege of joining them as a martial
for the car park on
friday afternoon as they administered
over 500 vaccines
but my rational friend says that he is
led by the data and not the dates
yet his statement outlines many dates so
will he
commit to publishing the thresholds of
data
that will determine the easing of
lockdown measures
prime minister i yes indeed
uh he can examine all the data that
we've uh uh we published today and
uh i've set out the criteria by which we
will uh proceed
uh and i thank him for what he's doing
to marshall people in the car parks
we now go to christina reese christina
ruiz
thank you madam deputy speaker on the
18th of february the uk government
announced
18.5 million pounds for four research
projects to better understand the causes
symptoms and treatment of lung covet
however the linkage between
sepsis and kobed on long come long
sepsis and long covered as evidenced by
the uk sepsis trust was not mentioned
would the prime minister please outline
his plans to make sure that this very
important linkage
will be included in these research
projects
prime minister of course we will look at
sepsis which i know is a deeply
distressing condition
and whether it has any association with
kobe
we now move to kate griffiths kate
griffiths
thank you madam deputy speaker i thank
the prime minister for setting out these
measures today
and i know everyone is keen to start
socializing in a safe way as soon as
possible
can i ask the prime minister to allow
pubs to reopen their gardens as quickly
as possible
if six people can buy alcoholic drinks
from shop and meet in a park
then i hope that pubs will be given a
chance to provide a takeaway service
for consumption in their gardens as soon
as possible
prime minister yes indeed and that's why
april the 12th is the day
christine matheson thank you madam
deputy speaker last month was the worst
on record for
new aircraft orders in the aerospace
sector which is so important to my
constituency
along with tourism travel and aviation
as we've heard we'll suffer
a long time after these restrictions are
lifted so will the prime minister commit
to continuing support for those areas
areas of the economy that drive so much
of the value in the economy but will be
take will suffer from
a much longer lag before they're able to
pick up again i'm in history
he's quite right that's why we've done
everything we can with time to pay
another means to try to look after the
the aviation sector though it's been
incredibly hard for that sector which
matters a great deal to
uh to our country the best way forward
for them is to get people
uh flying again uh as i've said i i know
it's a bit of a time to wait
but the travel task force will be
reporting uh on
uh april the 12th and you know i'm
hopeful that we'll be able to make
progress this summer but we'll have to
wait and see
now go to bill wiggin bill wiggin
thank you madam deputy speaker as a
animal welfare
champion i was delighted to hear the
prime minister mention zoos
but before we can get out there and go
to the pubs and visit
these places i heard him describe
certainty being more important than
urgency
and his concern for the unprotected
unvaccinated element of the population
who potentially could be holding the
rest of us back
what more can we do to encourage people
who might not have taken up the vaccine
to make sure they get jabbed and let the
rest of us out
prime minister it's it's i'm grateful of
course we must encourage everybody to
take the vaccine as i say is a wonderful
thing
uh one of the problems is that uh it's
at the moment we're not as as he knows
uh vaccinating children children
are not uh approved for uh for the
vaccine and though they are
uh possible vectors of the uh of the
disease
uh and there are people uh as as my
rather friend knows who are uh
vulnerable to the disease even though
they may have
uh been vaccinated there'll be at least
a percentage so we've got to
make sure we proceed uh with caution but
in a way that we don't have to go back
on
now move to drew hendry drew hendry
thank you madam deputy speaker does the
prime minister
and his government intend to do anything
at all
for the three million or so people
who've been excluded
from financial support since the start
of this pandemic
prime minister we've provided about 15
billion pounds for the
uh self-employed and we'll continue to
look after them in any way we can
now moving to craig tracy craig tracy
thank you madam deputy speaker and a
welcome prime minister setting out this
road map
as promised and it's great to see that
schools will be returning
including importantly with their
sporting activities
but with this in mind the 8th of march
will also have been the optimum time to
reintroduce
for everyone non-contact sports such as
golf which is scientifically proven
to be able to be participated in safely
during the pandemic
so cuba prime minister said out why it's
not been possible to do this at this
stage
as it will leave millions of people
having to wait for another five weeks
before they can return to their favorite
form of exercise
prime minister uh my honorable friend is
is is quite right to vent his
frustration i share his
frustration uh as somebody who yearns to
go out and
and play sport uh myself i understand
completely how he
uh he feels uh we must face the fact
that the the virus remains
uh by comparison any period last year
uh the virus remains very prevalent in
our
in our country uh and we have to
continue to
uh keep it under control uh what we what
we're trying to do is a cautious
uh but irreversible approach and uh
he only has to wait until for another
three weeks
uh beyond uh march the 8th uh to be able
to hit a golf ball
uh with a friend uh deadly speaker
now moving to emma lewell buck emma
little buck
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
the prime minister's handling of this
pandemic has been marked by false
promises in inconsistent messaging
hospitality was covered secure yet they
were imposed with an arbitrary curfew
then closed down and today this industry
which is the lifeblood of coastal
tourist towns like mine
i've heard that people can meet outside
in a park yet outdoor areas of safe
regulated pubs bars and restaurants
can't open till april they simply cannot
see the logic behind this
can the prime minister explain where he
found it
prime minister the logic madam deputy
speaker
lies in containing a pandemic and i
think people in this country
understand that but i can i and i deeply
sympathize with
uh the businesses in her uh constituency
uh
the wonderful hospitality sector across
the country
uh they have a date now uh to work for
uh to look forward to for outdoor
hospitality
and for indoor hospitality and i think
people rather have uh
certainty uh than anything else moving
to raymond tristy
raymond chisti thank you madam deputy
speaker further to my question to the
prime minister
on the 27th of january and
representations from medway mps
midway will now have a mass vaccination
center and i thank the primes from the
government
for that the impact of covet 19 on the
mental health and well-being of young
people has been repeatedly raised with
me
by local schools and the local
university the children's commissioner
anne longfield
has suggested that all schools should
have a dedicated
mental health worker in schools is that
something that the government will be
looking to take forward
or will there be specific alternative
support for young people and with that
i thank the prime minister for his
recent response to me with regards to
the report i sent him
from professor young at king's college
london on mental health and covert 19.
prime minister uh i congratulate him on
uh and the the the people reign them on
the uh vaccine center and everything
that they're
they're doing um on
mental health he's he's completely right
to to raise it but that's why we've
uh were investing massively in
supporting children's
uh and adult mental health and uh i've
recently appointed alex george
b a mental health ambassador for young
people
thank you very much madam deputy speaker
as the prime minister charts
his road map out of this third national
lockdown
undoubtedly he has presided over a
disastrous response to the pandemic
one of the worst in the world wherein
the sluggishness double mindedness and
mixed messaging
has led to billions of pounds of
taxpayer money
going into crony contracts to
firms with links to the tory party we've
got one of the worst
major economic crisis in the world of
any major economy
and the worst death toll within europe
wherein more than a hundred thousand
people have died
including members of my family so will
the prime minister like to take this
opportunity
to apologize to the british people and
reassure them that the steps that he is
now taking
will not lead us into yet another
lockdown
the purpose of this uh roadmap is to be
cautious but irreversible if i take it
from what he just said that he supports
that roadmap that i'm
glad to have his support we now go to
martin
vickers martin vickers thank you madam
deputy speaker
um i fully support the uh my right on
group of friends
cautious approach uh to the lockdown
however you will know that
coastal resorts have been particularly
badly hit
as they rely to a considerable extent on
the hospitality sector
that said northern lincolnshire and the
humber can play a major part
in the post-pandemic economic recovery
can the prime minister give an assurance
that the government will continue
to support both established and new
businesses in the area
prime minister yes indeed we will make
sure that we support
uh businesses throughout the pandemic
and i i'm
absolutely certain that uh the
hospitality industry in
in cleethorpes uh and uh surrounding
area
uh will bounce back very strongly indeed
boss cheryl ambassador
uh thank you madam dr speaker the prime
minister in his statement indicated that
wearing
face masks will still be a factor in the
fight against covert over the months
ahead
yet many people with hidden disabilities
are unable to wear face masks
and yet many of them face abuse when
they go out in public
and people don't realize that they're
exempt from wearing face coverings so
can the prime minister give a commitment
to have a public awareness campaign
for people within disability so they
don't face abuse in public
he raises a very important point and uh
i will make sure that we do even more to
get that point over to people so that
people who can't wear face masks because
of their
disabilities don't face that kind of
abuse
now go to sir john redwood sir john
will the government do more to improve
airflow and
control an extraction in health settings
and make more safe use of powerful
ultraviolet cleaners
to reduce cross-infection further
prime minister my my own friend raises a
very interesting point i know that
uh our scientific advisors are looking
at everything we can do including the
means he suggests in order to reduce
transmission of the disease
now go to stephen bonner stephen bonner
thanks madam deputy speaker scientific
research from leading scottish
universities has today showing
substantial reductions
in serious covert 19 hospital admissions
following administration
or the first doors of the vaccine given
the success does the prime minister not
agree with me
it is now time to prioritize critical
public servants
such as our teachers and other key
workers to ensure maximum protections
are embraced as we begin to ease our way
out of
i think that most people in this house
would agree madam
deputy speaker that the jcvi was right
in their
uh prioritization of the those who are
most vulnerable
and that are our ambition in the vaccine
rollout program
should be to vaccinate firstly uh those
who are most at risk of serious disease
and death and that is the the right
approach moving to andrew bowie
andrew barry thank you very much madame
deputy speaker i welcome my right
honourable friend statement this
afternoon and very much hope that is
matched by the first minister statement
to the scottish parliament tomorrow
because it is better for business not
least the tourism and hospitality
sector that the whole country moves at
the same pace in that vein
does the prime minister agree with me
that the incredible
success pace and take-up of the the
vaccine
just shows what this country can achieve
when we do it
together prime minister
he is completely right my honourable
friend is completely right it's been a
a stunning example of the whole of the
uk
working together to roll out a
a program that's been absolutely vital
for our whole country and
a cooperation with the da's has been
terrific on this
but it's something that could not have
been achieved without the uk
working together moving to it stephen
kinnick
stephen thank you madam deputy speaker
the
prime minister should know that there
can be no post-pandemic
economic recovery without a strong and
healthy
uk steel industry but he should also
know that our steel workers are having
to compete
with one hand tied behind their backs
because our electricity costs our steel
makers
86 more than germany and 62
more than in france what steps will the
prime minister be taking
to reduce british electricity costs to
internationally competitive levels
so that our steel industry can thrive in
the wake of this pandemic
uh prime minister uh he raises a very
important point and of course that was
one of the
uh the consequences of the uh of the
uh some of the taxes some of the uh
skewing of the prices that have been
chosen over many years by
uh by government uh we want to make sure
that we have
a steel industry in this country that is
able
uh to compete and that we must indeed
address
the discriminatory costs of of energy
he's completely right to raise it
just a quick reminder this is about the
kovid's statement
so we now move to andrew saloon
thank you very much on both of whit
snake zoo
but will the prime minister now instruct
that a further
test case be taken to the courts so that
those hospitality businesses whose
business interruption
insurance is still not paying out can
get the relief that they need having
paid
thousands in premiums for decades in
some cases
prime minister i i
do hope that the businesses concerned uh
receive the uh the compensation that
they
are owed and deserve from their
insurance
packages but in the meantime i i would
just urge him to to look out for what
the chancellor is going to say
uh next week by way of continued support
and i go to nasha
thank you madam deputy speaker i do
welcome the road map
that has been put before the house this
afternoon certainly because bradford has
had extra restrictions
since july and my question really to the
prime minister is he has outlined that
hospitality the industry will be open by
the 12th of april but
wedding industry walked before june the
21st
at the larger venues that's another 10
weeks for some businesses
that about 10 weeks could be the
difference between
closure and bankruptcy and we have some
amazing wedding venues in bradford it's
a big part of our
industry here and they can open
like restaurants with two meters apart
so i'd urge the
prime minister to reconsider whether we
could
look at wedding in wedding venues being
opened sooner and i would invite him
to come and look at some of our amazing
wedding venues in bradford west we have
so many beautiful ones thank you uh
prime minister
well i'm very happy to take up her
invitation to visit the beautiful
wedding
uh venues of bradford i know they have a
they have an extraordinary
uh they do an amazing job there but uh
just an answer to her point we can't do
full uh cecil b demille uh weddings
uh earlier than uh than june the 21st we
can do smaller
uh weddings before then as she knows but
at least uh the businesses that
the great businesses she talks about now
have a date to think about and to aim
for
richard fuller thank you very much madam
deputy speaker may i thank the prime
minister for his statement in particular
the inclusion of dates that help
businesses plan
but with respect to international travel
the inside
page of our passport states that in the
name of her majesty
all those whom it may concern to allow
the bearer to pass freely without let
off hindrance
and with regard to quarantine hotels may
i remind the prime minister
that just because a policy is popular
does not mean it is right
prime minister i have a high regard for
my
uh honorable friend uh who i've known
for for many years
uh and i know he speaks for uh for many
in our
in our party and uh and beyond in what
he says
uh these are very difficult judgments to
to make as i know he
uh he appreciates uh and i but i think
that it is right
uh when you're facing uh a pandemic like
this and the risk of new variants
to have a very tough uh borders and
quarantine policy indeed
now move to janet davey janet davey
thank you madam deputy speaker the prime
minister has been asked several times
about how the government procured
contracts during this pandemic
my question to the prime minister is
slightly different and if there are any
plans for the government to claw back on
any
of the funds on pandemic contracts that
have failed
for example delivering unusable or
unsafe ppe
at the great expense of the taxpayer
prime minister 99.5 of the pp that we
have received has been
uh of a high standard uh but of course
where
people have fallen down on their
contracts uh we will claw
back uh the money that we've paid
now move to paul bristow paul bristow
i want to congratulate rnhs and the my
right honourable friend for the great
british success story
that is the vaccination program because
the uk is ahead of others on vaccination
we can open up sooner my right
honourable friend said he would focus on
data
not dates but these five week dates seem
arbitrary
if progress against the four tests look
better than expected
might the government be flexible and
review the data
and restrictions on a weekly or
fortnightly basis
and not on pre-determined dates
prime minister these not before dates
aren't arbitrary they're they're crucial
and they
uh they're determined by the the time
you need
to evaluate the impact on the pandemic
of the openings up that we're doing and
so you need four weeks to see
for instance where the schools the
opening of schools uh has caused uh
an uncontrollable surge in the pandemic
and then a week to
uh to to give advice and so on so
they're not arbitrary they're dictated
by
uh the science and uh that is the the
right way forward but
if you look at the overall uh road map
uh it is i think uh beyond what
what many other countries are currently
able to achieve and that as he rightly
says
is thanks to the rollout of the
vaccination program
moving to andy slaughter andy slaughter
thank you madam deputy speaker five
local nhs
areas in england including houses and
fulham have vaccinated
73 or less of the over 70s
despite the very best efforts of nhs and
public health staff and volunteers
this falls to a 60 up for the most
deprived 10th
residents and below 50 for some ethnic
minority groups
as the country moves on to vaccinate
younger and less at-risk
groups what comfort can the prime
minister give
to the quarter of my elderly vulnerable
constituents
that his government have left behind
prime minister take up is accelerating
actually amongst all those groups but
he's right to say that it's been slower
in some groups than others and that's
why we've rolled out the network of
community champions but uh it's also
important for him
and for all of us uh ourselves to
champion
the uptake of vaccines across all our
communities in our constituencies
now moving to mike wood mike wood
thank you madam deputy speaker the
vaccine rollout has been more successful
than even the most optimistic of us
could have predicted in december
and while the prime minister is clearly
right to insist
that this uh that this roadmap
must be irreversible so that we don't
risk a further lockdown
will he make sure that if vaccinations
prove to be as effective as we all hope
the government can still continue to
review whether later stages
might progress more quickly as long as
the number of deaths and hospital
admissions continue to fall
prime minister he makes a very
uh interesting point which i'm sure that
uh will have
occurred to many other colleagues and to
people up and down the the country i've
given the reason for the interval
uh between uh the dates that i've set
out the re the
why we need to be able to certain be
certain about uh the impact of the
of the relaxations that we're we're
making the four weeks plus one that we
we need uh but the other point i would
make because he
he makes a very interesting but the
other point i make is i think people
would much
rather have a date that they uh
know is as as certain at this stage as
we can possibly be
uh to fix on and to work towards
rather than uh more uncertainty and
fluidity than we can do that we need
61 withdrawn so we go to james wilde
james
thank you madam deputy speaker last week
i met kathy the practice manager
and the team including volunteers at
james medical practice
who vaccinated thousands of people in
northwest norfolk
will my rival friend join with me in
paying tribute to them
and those other sites in kingsland and
schneidergen who are making it possible
to reopen our hospitality sector albeit
more slowly than some would want
as well as very importantly reopening
our schools and other businesses in the
coming weeks
prime minister uh yes i do and i i thank
everybody involved in the vaccination
program in northwest
uh norfolk and i thank my honorable
friend for for championing the
vaccinators
we go to allison fullest alison doulas
thank you very much
the appg gaps in support heard evidence
last week
on how tens of thousands of women have
been forgotten about during this
pandemic
so will the prime minister meet with the
maternity action pregnant then screwed
bethany power and smelly joshie to hear
how he can redress the balance and
unfair
how he can redress the unfairness that
those who were pregnant and on maternity
leave have faced during pandemic
prime minister she raises an important
but i'll certainly make sure that
the relevant minister receives such a
delegation now move to julian sturdy
julian sturdy
thank you madam deputy speaker in view
of the
prime minister's sensible commitment to
act on the basis of data and updates
which i
fully support can we clarify if there is
scope and flexibility
in his roadmap to go faster in relaxate
in relaxing restrictions if the
vaccination program proceeds more
rapidly than expected
and the data shows enhanced effect
effectiveness of the vaccine
as more of that data comes forward
resulting in radically reduced
transmission and hospital admissions
surely if we're following the data that
flexibility
has to work both ways
prime minister this is all i'm very
grateful to my honourable friend this is
already a a
very fast unlocking program by
uh by other international standards
the the timetable is dictated uh as i've
explained
uh by the intervals we need to evaluate
the effect of each successive
uh each successive lockdown and i think
what people want to see what businesses
want
is as much certainty as possible rather
than
uncertain and that's what we aim to
going to provide bradshaw ben bradshaw
forgive me madam deputy speaker i didn't
hear the prime minister's reply just
then because one of the zoom operators
was talking to another member
but the prime minister is absolutely
right to say that we should
be driven by the data and not dates and
that his dates
are therefore subject to review but
given the stunning
uh success of the vaccination program
with the evidence today
of how it prevents serious illness and
death why is he not prepared to bring
his dates forward
as well as back if the data justifies
that
prime minister as i uh he didn't hear my
answer to the last
uh question so i'll repeat it because
these questions really identical to
several previous questions the answer is
that you need
time to evaluate the success
or otherwise of each locta of each
unlocking
and you need four weeks to to see what's
happened and
bear in mind uh madam deputy speaker
that we are dealing with a disease that
is extremely
contagious and uh large numbers of
people who are still unvaccinated
and still very vulnerable so we have to
proceed with with caution
uh so that's why there's the the
interval the four
uh five-week interval that we have and
the second reason
is that uh we want a timetable uh that
we can stick to and i think people would
would really much rather have
a sense of certainty and security the
maximum possible
certainty and security rather than any
sense that
it's it's fluid again and they could uh
move one way
uh the the the date they have in their
heads
uh could change and i think that is uh
very very important certainty uh in this
particular case
this particular road map is a great
value
[Applause]
66 withdrawn so we go to geraint davis
gray davis thank you madam deputy
speaker
prime minister in wales excess
deaths over the five-year average are 13
more compared to 20 more in
england so will the prime minister
ensure
on the uk government website that it
says if you live
in more highly infectious areas of
england
you should not travel to wales
prime minister uh the restrictions
uh throughout the country apply both in
uh
uh england wells scotland uh and
northern ireland they will continue to
apply
uh for the duration of the pandemic
moving to robert halfon robert halfon
thank you uh madam deputy speaker i
really welcome the prime minister's
statement which will give certainty to
businesses and
constituents in harlow and it's really
good news about school we openings on
the 8th of march
given that so many children have lost
months of school
impacting their education attainment and
mental health
will he ensure that every pupil is
assessed for their loss of learning and
how much catch-up is needed
and will he consider extending the
school day not
by putting an extra burden on teachers
and support staff
but by using civil society to offer
sporting activities mental health
support and academic catch-up where
necessary
prime minister that's i thank my
honorable friend that that's exactly why
uh i i've appointed i've appointed uh
sir kevin collins
uh to be the educational recovery
commissioner to
champion all those ideas all those
initiatives that he's just
rightly mentioned and he'll be hearing
more about that all later this week
now going to joanna cherry joanna cherry
thank you madam deputy speaker while the
government's announcement the indoor
care home visiting for one named person
one named relative is to be permitted
for 8th march
while that sounds like progress the fact
that this remains a matter for guidance
only is very concerning
the joint committee on human rights has
heard too many examples of previous
guidance on this issue
not being followed denying meaningful
visits when these might safely be
facilitated
the joint committee has drafted
regulations that would ensure that
nobody in a care home was denied a
face-to-face visit without a carefully
thought through
individualized risk assessment will the
prime minister commit to bringing these
regulations into force
well i just directed the
uh right honourable lady to uh what i
said earlier on about
ensuring that people do get the ability
to see
a nominated uh visitor and
also to remind her of the sad reality of
the infection
that we've seen in care homes and the
need to protect against it there is a
balance to be struck as
as she knows richard harden thank you
very much madame deputy speaker and i
thank the prime minister for his
statement
everyone especially young people small
businesses in the hospitality and pub
sector
in northwestern but across the country
have made massive sacrifices
to achieve the huge progress in tackling
the pandemic
as long as the government's
world-leading vaccine program continues
the robot means we'll now be off almost
restrictions
by late june with that certain approach
the prime minister is pushing for
therefore can i extend to him an
invitation to the prime minister's
fiancee carrie
wilfred and dylan to visit northwest
durham this summer to see some of
britain's
most beautiful but least well-known
countryside
i i thank my uh honourable i can't think
i wild horses wouldn't keep me away from
uh
from north west durham tell him that
we now go to ass fell khan ashfal khan
thank you madame deputy speaker earlier
this month
nearly half of constituents are surveyed
reported severe levels of financial
insecurity
shockingly almost a third also said they
struggle to afford
daily living costs this is the financial
reality
of millions around the country one
respondent told me that they feel
hopeless utterly hopeless about their
financial situation
the prime minister could now deliver
some peace of mind for my constituents
by agreeing to extend the sports schemes
that have kept
many families afloat during this crisis
this includes expanding payments for
people self-isolating
will he do so prime minister
will continue to look after people
throughout the pandemic
jacob young thank you madam deputy
speaker our vaccine rollout so far has
been an amazing success
and i want to thank those at eston pcn
record hospital james cook
and the government for their efforts in
delivering it we're hitting targets and
reaching new milestones each day and
soon we will have the novavax
vaccine made in t side to help us as
well
can i ask the prime minister when he
express expects this new two-sided
vaccine
to be approved by the mhra
i was thrilled to go up to t side and to
see
the site whether the nova backs vaccine
will be made and in fact to look at one
of one of the bioreactors
uh that will be used um i can't give an
exact date by which the mhra
will give approval but uh we're pretty
confident madam deputy speaker that
would be
forthcoming before too long now going to
graham
morris graham morris
thank you madam deputy speaker is the
prime minister aware of the catch-up
with cancer campaign
and the urgent need for funding to care
to clear the cancer backlog otherwise we
risk
turning the corvid crisis into a cancer
crisis
with tens of thousands more lives lost
will he commit to the funding to create
a world-class
cancer service and work with the catch
up with cancer campaign
to deliver the investment we need in the
cancer workforce
in new equipment and in the it networks
that we urgently need to tackle this
backlog
prime minister yes and he makes a a very
important point that's why we're
in investing uh i think an extra 52
billion pounds into the nhs but also
tackling the
the backlog uh of caused by uh
the uh the pandemic in cancer and many
other uh conditions and i think
uh the point that he makes should be
attended to uh by all those who think
uh that it is uh somehow uh that another
wave of covid is something
uh we can simply uh put up with easily
uh madam deputy speaker the nhs is
already under terrific pressure
and the more coveted we have the more it
displaces other vital treatments
as he rightly as he rightly points out
now moving to ben bradley ben bradley
this morning i visited the manor academy
in munster woodhouse to see the amazing
job they've done setting up covered
testing for pupils and staff they're
very keen to see their children back
in school as they know the inequalities
that existed pre-coded
will only have been exacerbated by
closures so can my wrongful friend
assure the house
that wide-ranging support will be
offered to schools to address not just
academic issues but the social and
emotional challenges that many children
will face
as a result of those closures prime
minister yes and one of the most
important things i think you can do
uh is not just supporting kids mental
health
and addressing those issues uh helping
teachers to
uh to address them but also investing in
one-on-one tutoring that i think could
be of massive value
uh to kids who've come under particular
stress kids who've fallen behind
but also kids who may show great
potential
that needs to be unleashed man so
one-to-one tutoring is something we're
going to be investing in heavily
moving to dr rupa huck rupa huck
madden deputy speaker to add to the
various helter skelter of pending cliff
edge dates
uh stamp duty eviction ban business race
uc
furlough one ended yesterday little
known one when the four months of free
vitamin d
supplied to the shielding the expiry
date to claim ended
can you tell us will the 1.7 new
shielders just added to the list be
eligible for this can he advertise it
more widely
and indeed given how vitamin d builds
immunity to all viruses even for people
who are not yet eligible for their
vaccination can he commit
to a year-long advertising campaign for
all
kellogg's are on board will he do it
minister
i thank her very much for what she says
about vitamin d i think she's
she's right about the value uh that
vitamin can have
and we'll make sure that we give it a
due publicity
moving to mark menzies mark menses
thank you madam deputy speaker i would
like to welcome the prime minister's
statement today and also to acknowledge
the tremendous leadership that he has
shown in driving forward
the vaccine program but as my right
honourable friend is aware
tourism and hospitality sectors are
vital to the filed economy
and they are ready and willing to trade
their way to recovery can my right
honourable friend assure me
that he will keep the sector at the
front of his thoughts both ahead of next
week's budget
and when implementing his roadmap prime
minister
the tourism sector has is absolutely
vital for our country
and the faster we can get it open uh the
better uh
and the the best way to open it up uh
the fastest is to have a
a road map from which we don't deviate
and which on which we're not forced to
to go backwards and that's what we're
we're sitting out today i'm glad we have
his support
going to ruth cadbury with cadbury
thank you madam deputy speaker the prime
minister has today both acknowledged the
importance of holidays abroad
but also that strict quarantine is
essential
to address global transmission of covid
the aviation sector
has estimated that at best aviation will
only return
in the uk to a third of 2019 levels this
year
and full recovery could take five years
so
when will the government be releasing
their delayed aviation recovery plan
and what additional support will the
government be providing
for communities like mine and like the
prime ministers
who are very dependent on the aviation
sector for employment
prime minister she'll be hearing a lot
more about that and other matters on
on april the 12th moving to dr james
davis
dr james davis thank you madam deputy
speaker
my right honourable friend has quite
rightly placed an emphasis on the
reopening of schools
with a return to school of all children
in england on the 8th of march
in wales primary school children aged 7
and under
will return this week while it's hoped
that the remainder of primary school
children
and some older pupils taking
qualifications may return on the 15th of
march
however there appear to be no plans for
most secondary school pupils to return
in wales until after easter
potentially beyond the reopening of some
non-essential shops
will the prime minister urge the welsh
government to reconsider its approach
given the harm that young people have
already endured
during this pandemic minister
well thank my uh honorable friend
obviously that is a matter for the
devolved
authority uh but i'm sure i uh he shares
my
my hope that uh all pupils will be back
in school as fast as possible that we'll
hear from
uh from the the labour party in wales
that schools are safe
moving to maria eagle marie regal
thank you madam deputy speaker in
liverpool only 23 percent of those who
applied for test trace and isolate
payment received it
and over two-fifths of them received a
discretionary payment from money which
is now
exhausted now um effectively
facilitating isolation is going to be
key in preventing the resurgence of the
virus by a new strains which might
compromise the vaccine so does the prime
minister accept
that eligibility for the test trace and
isolate payment
is not drawn widely enough to provide
support to those who need it
and who can't afford to stop work
without extra help
and will he agree to extend it to
include all of those people
who have no access to statutory sick pay
prime minister we will continue to
support uh all those
who are i say indeed we will uh
do what we can to increase uh our
support for them
uh but we will also uh support everybody
throughout this
uh this pandemic and she should wait for
the the chancellor
and the budget next week steve bryant
thank you madam deputy speaker i want to
welcome and indeed raise a hallelujah
that the good sense
and we're standing with parents and
children and schools for all pupils will
return from march the 8th
it's the right thing to do on so many
levels can i ask the prime minister
though
what evidence has driven his decision
that outdoor sport not not in school
outdoor sport wider outdoor sport
for those same children cannot go ahead
for at least another month
and after all the good work that they've
done last year to create covert secure
environments
restaurants and cafes face another three
months
before they can open in any meaningful
way what is the evidence that he's seen
that's convinced him to make that
decision today
thank you actually uh i thank my own
actually outdoor uh support for for
schools can go ahead from
uh march the eighth as i said uh earlier
on and
the evidence for uh all the decisions
that we've taken
a massive quantity of scientific
evidence has been uh deposited today
with the house
we now go to yvette cooper yvette cooper
thank you madam deputy speaker our
covered rates in yorkshire have fallen
much more slowly than in london and the
south
east partly because fewer people can
work from home
and more people in our towns have to go
out to work to keep our factories and
distribution centers running
the prime minister keeps saying he's
supporting self-isolation but most
workers are not
getting that support and that is
particularly hitting and manufacturing
towns
so will he think again will he extend
that support help those workers and help
us get our rates down
prime minister thank her we are we are
indeed
uh increasing our support as i said for
uh people who are self-isolating and
continue to look after
uh workers throughout the pandemic uh
but the best thing
uh for all those businesses is to is to
continue as they're doing in yorkshire
to get the uh get the disease uh down
and keep it under control
i'm afraid we've mislayed alex
shellbrook but we will try to return to
him
so we move straight to vicky foxcroft
deputy speaker disabled people have been
one of the hardest hit groups during
this pandemic
communication with disabled people and
those shielding
has been poor far too often
communications have been late
and not in accessible formats but the
prime minister can seek to rectify this
now
will he provide a clear road map for
those people shielding
so they know when it's safe for them to
rejoin society
prime minister yes indeed uh and it's
it's here
uh it's the road map that she uh should
uh have
with her now or she is online now uh and
uh the the measures uh specifically for
a disabled people for those shielding
are clearly set out now moving to
simon clark simon clark
thank you madam deputy speaker i
congratulate my right on refund on his
sensible and measured
statement just as i echo honorable fend
for red car and thanking all those
across the tees valley involved in the
vaccine roll out so far
children and parents will be delighted
that schools across england return on
the 8th of march
i fear greatly that white working-class
children were born the brunt
in terms of uh lack of progress in
educational attainment during this time
can i urge a specific focus on targeted
support for those young
people as we rebuild our country
we will i'm really grateful we will
support uh
all uh pupils who've suffered uh
lost to their learning uh as a result of
the
of the of the pandemic and that's why
i think we've got 1.3 million laptops
we've now uh distributed
uh put another billion and 1.3 billion
into uh catch-up of all kinds but you
know he's totally right
to focus on this it is i think uh the
number one challenge the country faces
now
kat smith thank you madam deputy speaker
our university university students many
of whom were not eligible for furlough
for their part-time jobs
were already struggling financially
today's road map suggests the vast
majority of those students won't be able
to return to their university
accommodation until after easter
at best they're legally being prevented
from returning to accommodation they're
obliged to play for
does the prime minister think this fair
and if he doesn't think it's fair what's
he going to do about it
prime minister
we i sympathize deeply with
uh students who've had an absolutely uh
you know
a term at a time at university uh
that no other generation has has put up
with uh i
sympathize deeply with their sense uh of
unfairness the
the experiences that they've had they've
also been heroic by the way
in the way that they've been able to
bring the disease down
in some of their university times
through through obeying the
the guidance we will do whatever we can
uh to support them working with
the university sector to make up for
what they've uh the experiences they've
been through making sure
that insofar as we can we help them to
get compensation
mark fletcher thank you madam deputy
speaker and i very much welcome the
prime minister's statement today in a
sustainable way
out of this situation and it is
absolutely right that we
prioritize the reopening of schools and
getting all children
back into the classroom does the prime
minister agree with me that is now
essential that we work with parents and
teachers and schools to develop a
long-term plan
for pupils to catch up on the education
that they have missed out on
particularly in areas like bolsover
my honourable friend is absolutely right
and that's why
uh sir kevin collins has been appointed
as the education recovery
commissioner and we'll be setting out
plans that are intended uh not just to
remediate the loss that uh kids have
suffered during the pandemic but also to
take
our educational system forward and to do
things that possibly we wouldn't have
done
uh before to find new ways of teaching
and learning that will
uh will make up the difference for those
kids and more
so we've relocated alex shelbuck so
we'll go now to him alex shellbrook
thank you madam deputy speaker manager
speaker in my constituency there are a
lot of strong community events
especially things such as zumba classes
which i get a lot of emails on
so could i ask my right honourable
friend when does he envisage that indoor
activities in village halls and the like
for zumba classes may be allowed to
start again
prime minister uh
by the deputy speaker if you can do
outdoor zumba
uh then you could then obviously uh
um uh march the 29th uh
is is the is the is the date uh for you
always assuming you can't do it
one-on-one
uh in which case um you could uh you
could do it earlier
uh but uh indoor
as as he would have picked up from what
i've said earlier is is
uh currently down for
may may the 17th may the 17th along with
all other indoor settings
we now go to navento mishra
madam deputy speaker macmillan cancer
support has warned that more than 100
000 people live with cancer in the uk
are struggling to cover basic living
costs due to the impact of curbid 19.
tragically many cancer patients are
having difficulty paying for essentials
have experienced suicidal thoughts in
recent months will the prime minister
commit to making the 20 pound per week
universal credit
increase permanent and extend this
uplift to legacy benefits
prime minister he's totally right to
raise the
uh the issue of cancer patients other
patients who
need treatment and we're going to do
everything we can to clear the backlog
as fast as we possibly can it's one of
the reasons we've got to keep the covid
virus
going down uh madam deputy speaker and
he'll be hearing more
next week from the chancellor about
supporting people across the country
so edward lee um it seems to me that
many of the
88 people who've gone before me
and who've been critical of the prime
minister have been wise after the event
so let me now do precisely that and
plead guilty to this charge
if severe quarantine measures from the
very start of being so effective as in
australia
and equally if tough local lockdowns
have been effective in china
doesn't that rather beg the question why
we didn't do it over a year ago
i don't say this to be difficult but to
learn from the future
and to ponder on what we should do next
time
and i think many people in the country
think that it's better to be tough on
foreign travel
than tough on children attending school
i think he speaks for many people in the
in the country uh
my own friend when he says that we do
have a very tough
uh regime on uh international travel one
of the toughest
in the world and we will certainly be
making sure we learn all the lessons we
need to about
the early handling of the pandemic
now go to kerry mccarthy kerry mccarthy
thank you madam deputy speaker events
and
exhibitions companies in my constituency
are
still struggling to get any support um
for lost business
the fact that they're not customer
facing means they don't get the retail
hospitality grant
the fact they haven't actually been
forced to close or
they service businesses that have means
that they've lost out on the council's
lsrg
closed grant they're not arts
organizations as such so they don't get
the arts council funding
and the advice and guidance has been
given to local councils about what
grants they should be
giving to events in exhibition sector is
incredibly vague and inconsistent
so what reassurance can the prime
minister give me that in the
chancellor's budget next week
there will be finally be help for those
companies like the ones in my
constituency that are just
absolutely at their yeah their last legs
prime minister i'm acutely conscious of
the
businesses that have fallen through the
cracks as it were
uh madam deputy speaker wholesalers for
instance who find it difficult to
qualify under
uh one scheme or another we're doing
absolutely everything we can to
to make sure that we give the support
that uh that people want
uh there's extra discretionary funding
available for for councils to support
such businesses and
uh she will be hearing more certainly
from the chancellor next week
anthony mangle thank you madam deputy
speaker and i welcome the prime
minister's statement so
boris johnson are still speaking in the
commons but now we know how and when
it is likely we will uh come out of all
this
setting out his uh roadmap his so-called
roadmap
all dependent on four tests he said
tests involving the vaccine rollout
the vaccine effectiveness surge in cases
not putting pressure on the nhs
and any variants that emerge subject to
those tests
there will be four steps in five weeks
apart
so four steps five weeks apart the first
step march the eighth you can see there
all schools can return you can also meet
one other person outside
there'll be limited changes too on march
29th with a rule of six
some outside sport golf and tennis
included
then step two april
the 12th when non-essential retail and
hairdressers
can reopen plus gyms
plus holiday let's for families plus
significantly pubs and restaurants
outside
that's uh from april the 12th and from
may the 17th
pubs and restaurants indoors theaters
and concert halls
some sports events subject to capacity
limits
limited crowd numbers at sports events
from
may the 17th and then finally if all
goes to plan
uh the 21st of june and
the hope then is that uh most
if not all legal limits will
be removed and boris johnson said the
vaccine program has massively changed
the odds in our favor
some will want us to go faster but in
the end
we have to take it cautiously the end is
in sight and a wretched year he said
will give way to a spring
and summer that will be very
different boris johnson still speaking
in
the commons but we're going to take a
break coming next we'll have
all the analysis of what the prime
minister had to say
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news
entertainment podcast but wherever you
are welcome to
the safety rage what's the day podcast
for the ones who want to know more
welcome to the all out politics podcast
for the news story listeners
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free
[Music]
toxic masculinity are these ideals that
we can tell ourselves a really positive
for example uh never crying but you go
through difficult situations in life
and you realize that actually those
ideals can be quite detrimental to your
mental health
i mean i was conditioned from a young
age that what makes a man is strength
and dominance and never crying and
getting on with things really quickly
i think growing up on a council estate
had a part to play in that and i think
culturally being a first generation brit
and having to really
fight every day my parents um to make
away
in this country probably contributed as
well but when my dad
passed away in 2017 i tried my best to
be you know this
kind of macho man that never cried but
it didn't really work for me
and i ended up three months later kind
of breaking down
in floods of tears on a beach somewhere
and after i had cried
it was one of the the most freeing
moments i'd ever felt in my life and
that's when i started to explore maybe
what i was taught and conditioned to
believe made a man
wasn't truly accurate when i was 15
years old
one of my friends got murdered on the
council estate and
everything within me wanted to grieve
and
cry and show emotion but because i had
this picture that men can
only be strong i suppressed it and it
started to damage me on the inside for
the years to come so you're absolutely
right there's nothing wrong with being
strong
but i think when your body and your mind
is telling you that you need to
express emotion and you need to let it
out it's absolutely fine to do so
[Music]
i'm alex crawford and i'm sky's special
correspondent based in istanbul
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back so now we know how and when
restrictions could be lifted
our science correspondent thomas moore
is in the newsroom but let's uh talk
first to our deputy
political editor sam coates so sam uh
first of all what did you make of the
statement is it the kind of detail that
you're expecting
yes i think that what boris johnson has
done is
set out a lockdown lifting plan which
judging by the answers to his questions
and the points made in the house of
commons
chamber broadly commands uh the support
of the house of commons
i think he has managed to come up with a
plan that's perhaps slightly slower than
some people want
but bound people in with this promise
that it will be irreversible
now that means that he is essentially
committing that there will never be
a lockdown number four that's how he got
cabinet ministers to agree to it
yesterday
and that's how he sold it to the mps in
the house of commons chamber and
effectively uh to the country there was
a huge amount of detail
both about the nuances of the plans what
you can and cannot do at each stage
but there was also a lot of detail about
the
thinking underpinning uh boris johnson's
approach i think that some of that was
amongst the most fascinating i think the
key point to home in on
uh the thing that i think will reassure
some of those who wanted to get him to
go
faster uh and see the the timetable
rolled out slower
was a commitment that boris johnson
isn't through this plan
trying to target getting rid of
coronavirus altogether
uh as a necessity before starting to
lift lockdown as we on sky news have
been saying all morning
the r number the reproduction rate
doesn't have to be below one
cases don't have to be going down in
order to trigger
each of the new phases the uh four or
five if you count the
first stage as uh as the two that it
really is uh
and instead you can have cases going up
but the other metrics that they're using
going down and you can still
push through them and also a concession
that there is going to be coronavirus
in society because uh vaccines are not
completely effective because
some people won't have them kids don't
take them and they aren't entirely
effective so the admission of the kind
of realities of the plan i think will
help bind in some of his
uh backbenchers who otherwise would have
been nervous uh but yes boris johnson by
getting kierstarma and his backbenchers
on the side clearly has the votes
and the political support from today's
plan sam uh
just uh say a second let's bring in
thomas more so thomas these
four tests um obviously as uh
sam was saying vaccines key and
good news on on the effectiveness of of
vaccines today
yes certainly some good news mark but
it's it's not a perfect vaccine that we
have and that is the problem it's going
to be extremely difficult to reach herd
immunity that might suppress infection
levels to very
low rates and that is what is the peril
in in lifting lockdown particularly too
quickly what we've heard today is
is really a some dates for our diaries
it doesn't sound like the data is really
driving policy there is a huge
uncertainty
to the data and partly because of the
vaccines and
and and how much uh virus would still
spread
as lock down is eased but also because
of these uh these variants which are
are cropping up and they're not just
cropping up abroad so
any uh travel quarantine is not going to
exclude the possibility
of these these arising at home that we
have homegrown
variants that are going to cause more
more disease
in the future and that really does make
it very very difficult
uh to guarantee that we really will have
lifted
all lockdown measures by the summer is
your sense is it that this was a road
map
very much approved by his scientific
advisers
well certainly a lot of the language
being used chimed with
a briefing that i attended with the
chief scientific officer
uh earlier today um apply data not dates
and make sure that there is this good
four to five week gap between
each step and the lockdown and so on but
they were
very they were adamant that this does
need to be done
extremely cautiously and that however
good we think the vaccine is
it's not like the measles vaccine where
you can get
the the virus suppressed to the extent
where it simply cannot be transmitted
to anyone else the coronavirus vaccines
just
aren't that good and as sam said a fifth
of the population the children
are not going to have the vaccine and
then you've got all those who don't want
it or can't have it
so there's going to be an awful lot of
vulnerable vulnerable people
to this this virus and they are the ones
who would be at risk of going into
hospital
and dying if lockdown is lifted too soon
and allowing
contact between people but also allows
the virus to spread
okay and just uh sam a last word
with you i mean what is it hospitality
in
pubs and restaurants opening indoors is
still three months away effectively so
there will be
pressure on the chancellor now to do
more
extend what he's been doing absolutely
and
to be honest i think boris johnson told
us what rishi sunak is going to announce
in the budget next week which is an
extension probably for six months to an
awful lot of those schemes to get us
through
uh coronavirus um and i think what's
interesting about that is it probably is
gonna be
uh six months because today the prime
minister outlined a timetable until
june and he hopes it is june could be
extended um
for what he says is pretty much total
reopening
but it's interesting what won't have
happened by that point let me just run
you
through the list at that point in june
they'll still be the one meter plus rule
that requires you to say a certain
distance away
from others internally uh there is no
certainty at the moment about
international travel whether that will
be
back on the agenda clearly huge
enthusiasm inside government for that to
be the case
but they can't say yet and it takes two
to tango you've got to see what
other countries do and they haven't yet
worked out how mass events will work
will this uh mass testing plan that
you've read a bit about you've heard a
bit about from us
that they're clearly thinking about
really solve entry into nightclubs entry
into
uh concerts and help get stadiums fully
back
open rather than just half full which is
the promise at the moment and what will
happen with vaccine passports but
the one thing we know is they don't want
to call them vaccine passports um but
uh that's uh that's one of the uh things
that they are
looking at to let you into various
events okay sam
thank you very much indeed and thomas
more thank you as well
and just a reminder that the prime
minister will be holding a
news briefing from downing street he
will be speaking to the nation at seven
o'clock
uh this evening and he'll be joined by
the government's chief scientific
advisor
patrick valance and the chief medical
officer for
england that's uh professor chris witte
and we'll be bringing you a special
program easing the lockdown that'll
is with uh anna botting and that is
tonight
from 9 00 pm
now just time for a quick look at the
weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
northern and western parts will be very
wet and windy tomorrow with a
risk of flooding the met office have
issued amber warnings for heavy rain
over parts of scotland and yellow
warnings for
much of the north there are amber and
yellow warnings for ireland
too before then it'll be mainly dry this
evening
but the west of ireland will turn wet
and windy ireland
northern ireland and scotland will see
rain tonight while
england and wales will be mostly dry
although the north west can expect some
patchy rain later
western parts will be mild but windy
with gales on coasts and hills
the karma east will be a bit